human vision is amazingly beautiful and
complex it all started billions of years
ago where small organisms developed a
mutation that made them sensitive to
light fast-forward to today and there's
an abundance of life on the planet which
all have very similar visual systems
they include eyes for capturing light
receptors in the brain for accessing it
and a visual cortex for processing it
genetically engineered and balanced
pieces of a system which help us do
things as simple as appreciating a
sunrise but this is really just the
beginning in the past 30 years we've
made even more strides to extending this
amazing visual ability not just to
ourselves but to machines as well the
first type of photographic camera was
invented around 1816 where a small box
held a piece of paper coated with silver
chloride when the shutter was open the
silver chloride would darken where it
was exposed to light now 200 years later
we have much more advanced versions of
the system that can capture photos right
into digital form so we've been able to
closely mimic how the human eye can
capture a light in color but it's
turning out that that was the easy part
understanding what's in the photo is
much more difficult consider this
picture my human brain can look at it
and immediately know that it's a flower
our brains are cheating since we've got
a couple million years worth of
evolutionary context to help immediately
understand what this is but a computer
doesn't have that same advantage to an
algorithm the image looks like this just
a massive array of integer values which
represent intensities across the color
spectrum there's no context here just a
massive pile of data it turns out that
the context is the crux of getting
algorithms to understand image content
in the same way that the human brain
does and to make this work we use an
algorithm very similar to how the human
brain operates using machine learning
machine learning allows us to
effectively train the context for a data
set so that an algorithm can understand
what all those numbers in a specific
organization actually represent and what
if we have images that are difficult for
a human to classify can machine learning
achieve better accuracy for example
let's take a look at these images of
sheep dogs and mops where it's pretty
hard even for us to differentiate
between the two with the machine
learning model we can take a bunch of
images of sheep dogs and mops and as
long as we feed it enough data it will
eventually be able to properly tell the
difference between the two computer
vision is taking on increasingly complex
challenges and is seeing accuracy that
rivals humans performing the same image
recognition tasks but like humans
these models aren't perfect they do
sometimes make mistakes the specific
type of neural network that accomplishes
this is called a convolutional neural
network or CNN CNN's worked by breaking
an image down into smaller groups of
pixels called a filter each filter is a
matrix of pixels and the network does a
series of calculations on these pixels
comparing them against pixels in a
specific patterns the network is looking
for in the first layer of a CNN it is
able to detect high-level patterns like
rough edges and curves as the network
performs more convolutions it can begin
to identify specific objects like faces
and animals how does a CNN know what to
look for and if it's prediction is
accurate this is done through a large
amount of labeled training data when the
CNN starts all of the filter values are
randomized as a result its initial
predictions make little sense each time
the CNN makes a prediction against
labelled data it uses an error function
to compare how close its prediction was
to the images actual label based on this
error or a loss function the CNN updates
its filter values and starts the process
again ideally each iteration performs
with slightly more accuracy what if
instead of analyzing a single image we
want to analyze a video using machine
learning at its core a video is just a
series of image frames to analyze a
video we can build on our CNN for image
analysis
in still images we can use CNN's to
identify features but when we move to
video things get more difficult since
the items are identifying might change
over time or more likely there's context
between the video frames that's highly
important to labeling for example if
there's a picture of a half-full
cardboard box we might want to label it
packing a box or unpacking a box
depending on the frames before and after
it this is where CNN's come up lacking
they can only take into account spatial
features the visual data in an image but
can't handle temporal or time features
how a frame is related to the one before
it to address this issue we have to take
the output of our CNN and feed it into
another model which can handle the
temporal nature of our videos this type
of model is called a recurrent neural
network or our nm while a CNN treats
groups of pixels independently an RNN
can retain information about what it's
already processed and use that in its
decision-making rnns can handle many
types of input and alpha data in this
example of classifying videos we train
the RNN by passing in a sequence of
frame descriptions empty box open box
closing box and finally a label packing
as the RNN processes each sequence uses
a loss or error function to compare its
predicted output with the correct label
then it adjusts the weights and
processes the sequence again until it
achieves a higher accuracy the challenge
with these approaches to image and video
models however is that the amount of
data we need to truly mimic human vision
is incredibly large if we train our
model to recognize this picture of a
duck as long as we're given this one
picture with this lighting color angle
and shape we can see that it's a duck
but if you change any of that or even
just rotate the duck the algorithm might
not understand what it is anymore
now this is the big picture problem to
get an algorithm to truly understand and
recognize image content the way the
human brain does you need to feed it
incredibly large amounts of data of
millions of objects across thousands of
angles all annotated and properly
defined the problem is so big that if
you're a small start-up or a company
lean on funding
there's just no resources available for
you to do that
this is why technologies like Google
cloud vision and video can help Google
digests and filters millions of images
and videos to train these api's we've
trained a network to extract all kinds
of data from images and video so that
your application doesn't have to
with just one REST API request we're
able to access a powerful pre-trained
model that gives us all sorts of
metadata here's how easy it is to call
the cloud vision API with curl I'll send
this image to the API and here's the
response we get back billions of years
since the evolution of our sense of
sight we found that computers are on
their way to matching human vision and
it's all available as an API if you'd
like to know more about the cloud vision
and video api's check out their product
pages at the links here to see how you
can easily add machine learning to your
application thanks for watching
[Music]